a short time ago the president you may
have heard if you were listening brought
up ms-13 in America here's what he said
just two days ago our department of
justice charge 22 members of the savage
brutal horrible gang ms-13
in California
we've been violently operating for more
than 10 years we got them all we think
they are no good with conducting brutal
medieval style killings in art medieval
stylers prosecutors have charged 22
ms-13 members with a series of brutal
murders 19 of those gang members were in
this country illegally
chief breaking news correspondent friend
trace Gallagher has more on that tonight
trace
Tucker hua California has been fighting
to support sanctuary cities in fighting
against the Trump administration's
immigration policies law enforcement
authorities say 22 ms-13 members 19 as
you say in the country illegally
systematically and brutally killed at
least seven people using as the
president said medieval-style killing
techniques that federal law enforcement
haven't seen in two decades listen to
this one of the defendants allegedly
carved out his heart before throwing the
body parts into a canyon one victim was
killed for crossing out ms-13 graffiti
another was a homeless man who made the
fatal mistake of falling asleep in a
park that ms-13 considers its gang turf
the 22 gang members arrested are also
thought to be responsible for hundreds
of other crimes in several other states
we should note that the administration
is trying to address the crisis of the
border by making the requirements to
apply for asylum stricter Nancy Pelosi
says it's cruel and unusual Pelosi is
talking about the Trump administration
but we should have mentioned the Obama
administration said the same thing
listen to this
typically refugee status is not granted
just based on
economic need or because a family lives
in that neighborhood or poverty it's
typically defined fairly narrowly
amazing how time flies five years ago
Tucker Gallagher man with a long memory
great to see you trace